GRNDN KREMATORSK, ALSO NEW R TWR
AT QUOTE,
UNPRECEDENTED COEQ
THOSE KEO
THE COUNTRY.
YLIE
STARK WARNING TE S UNPRECEDENT
T SAY WHAT TARE.
HOHENG?
>> Repor Y
RATION
OFFICIALS ARE SAYING IS THESN
CONTINUED MILITARY S FOR
UKRAINE, STATEEPARTM
PUBLIC,D
ADMINISTRATION OF THDEN
THEY'RE OY OF THUED MILITARY SU
UKRAINE AND THE TIMELINE HERDE O
OUR REPORTING IS THIS DIPLOMATIC
NOTE RECEIVED BY THE BIDEN
MIN TUESDAD
PRESIDENT BIDEN WENT FTH WITH
MILITARY FROM THS. L
TO UKRAI ON DAY,INDICATING THAT
, THEY WEREN'TOING TO
IR
HU MILUS   NDICATES ABOUT
SUT INCTIVE AND SOME
DIPLOMATIC NOTE IF THEY FELT
AT THE STAT, LET'S IE FOR THRE
TA L M
IN ARMADIEL METT ANDOND FO CIAL
OVER SAW RSIPYING,ETE
GOTHIS WITH YOE PLO
GIVING WEANS TO T DOES TT EVEN
NS
>> WELL FIRST OF ALL, TH PUTOMA
SOMETHING THATOSBASIS INSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT.
IF THERE WERE REAL
UNPREDICTABLE CONSEQUE A MEANT O
DOINGS
LYO OR SN  I
THINISAST USINE TYPIL
OTORTH
>> SO RONALDI MEAN ONE OF THE CC
BE, LET'S HOPE NOTD TIN USINA,
INOU AUCNTLLD CID THEN WE JUST M
HORETHSSIBILITY IS TONIGHT?
WELL,.
NE FAR HE'S WILLING ANTS AN OB
O OMETHING ELSE,
ERYONE'S FRIGHTENED OF
MILITARY WNST USED ON LE FIELD
FATHER OF ALL S A
THERMOBARIC BOMB, D THEY USE T
BA FY
YOU KNOW, I WOD 'S BUT NOT A
PRITY. GENER KIMMITTU.
SECRETARY OF STATE ANTONY
WAR COULD LAST THROUGHND 202D W
TACTICS TO BECE BRUTAL
AS THIAC OF HINK WE GOT
TO LOOK AT THE NEWERN
, GEDUVORINIKOV IS A
AD O ERATIONS AGAS EP D
FEEL UNCONSTRAINED OLE
BBE WLI
USE
Y GH
S, TSE
THESE OFFENS
WOULPESEE CONTINUE
SHELLING, CONTINUED
HUTS
CONT ON CIVILIANRG I DON'T THIN
LEVELLD SEE OVER THE
NEXT MONTH TO SEE CON SSNST THI
DESIGNATE RUSSIA S S
DO YOU THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
E ADMINIRA
EFFORT.AN YOU DO VEE
BAYST I MEAN IS KOREA,
NORT
ET CETERA
NCS AND ALL , MOREOUT THEIR LON
SURE FRA WHEN ALYMBOLIC, IT'S II
AT THIMO BUT I UNDERSTAND TO HA
WHEN IT'S ALL SAID AONI
E  OF IT.AL KIMMIT IN
NATING I
WEAPONS E NEEDS THE MOST,  INA
THTI WEST, STRUCK
HE SAID WHEN SOME LES
WHAT WEAPONSNEED A
MOMENT TO CALMBEE READY TOLD TH.
FEE BILL MUR
OBVIOUSLY KNOWING THE AUENE'CLUT
IT DO  HE EL I
YOE?
D TO TELL.
>>IG GOTBALANCED AGATHE UNITED S
ATION
H NATO AND NATO IS AN TION OF 3O
KEU WANTO
MATAOFTE  TO E LO
COMMONENWO
OBJECT TO NOEEARE WORRIED A TOOS
IN TAI            THIS POINT,
M TO B
ASCOENOMINATOR.S OFDE
ZELENSKYY MAY BE TSIVE T THE I M
E COALITN
COUNTRIES
BIDED  O
SOME OUNIE